Here's everything my husband eats in a day,
slash what I cook for him.
Cooking is my love language,
so this is not something that's expected of me.
This is just something that I love doing.
So I started off by making some buttermilk syrup
for my French toast I'm about to make.
Then I cracked some eggs, combined that with some heavy cream,
nutmeg, cinnamon,
and a splash of vanilla before mixing that until it's combined.
I went on to slicing some brioche bread,
some strawberries, and then moving on to making my heavy cream.
I combined heavy cream with some powdered sugar and vanilla
before beating that until it was fluffy.
Dip my brioche bread, fried it up,
and then topped it with my syrup,
the heavy cream, and the strawberries.
Lucky specifically requested this breakfast,
and he ended up having three more plates after this.
I always need a midday beverage.
Today it was a watermelon cucumber sparkling mocktail.
For lunch, I was making some tacos,
so I started out by making my corn tortillas.
Once those were all cooked,
I set them aside in a towel
before moving on to charring some lemon and lime.
Lucky has been asking me to make some sort of chimichurri,
so I made a charred lemon chimichurri,
but also added some cilantro to it.
I chopped all of my ingredients,
topped with more of the lemon,
seasoned it, and then set it aside while I marinated my chicken.
This was A chipotle pepper and maple chicken.
It was perfectly smoky, spicy,
but also a slight bit sweet.
And I topped my tacos with some of that chimichurri,
some lime, and some extra chilies.
Now, he gave these a 9.7 out of 10,
which is a very high rating.
Comes to him. He liked them so much that he had about 16 more.
This turned out to be a very late dinner,
but I wanted it to be simple and just whatever we had in the fridge.
So I decided to make some duck fat,
roasted potatoes, red wine gravy,
and then Lucky's favorite vegetable lately has been broccoli knees,
so I made a lemon garlic broccoli knee.
I also bought these German sausages a couple days ago,
so I thought they'd be. And then it was time to plate.
This meal always hits the spot,
and it's so, so good.
After dinner, lucky wanted something sweet,
so he had some of these lemon basil popsicles I made earlier today.